In 1 Peter 3.15, Peter wrote this,
But in your hearts, set apart Christ as Lord.
Always be prepared to give an answer to everyone who asks you,
to give a reason for the hope that you have.
But do this with gentleness and respect.
Oftentimes when we're talking about things like apologetics,
this verse is sort of the foundational verse that everyone seems to cite.
Why? Well, because in this verse is where we get the idea of apologetics.
So Peter is asking us or commanding us to give a reason.
He's saying give an actual reason.
Well, what does it mean to give a reason?
Well, in this context, it means to give a defense.
Give some kind of defending idea of what it means about what you believe.
This is actually the Greek word apologia.
And that's where we get the idea of apologetics.
It literally comes from the word apology.
Now we're not talking about I'm apologizing for what I believe.
But if you can imagine for a moment a courtroom scenario
where you were on the stand and you had to give sort of a defense,
you had to give a reason for your actions, a reason for what you believe,
or a reason just for what you're doing.
Well, in the ancient world, in the context that Peter is talking about here
is to a bunch of Christians who are being persecuted by the Roman government.
Now here, Peter's telling the believers to be prepared,
to know why you believe what you believe,
to be able to stand in a formal sense in this context
to give a reason, to give a defense,
to defend one's belief in something.
And we take this command that Peter gives the early Christians
and we say, you know what, we have the exact same responsibility in our day.
It's to be able to stand when the questions come
and be able to give a reason for what we believe and why we believe it.
So essentially this is what apologetics is
and this is what your students are going to embark on this coming year.
But it's more than just making a defense.
It's the idea that we are both called
but we're also called to be capable.
See, it's more than just saying, I have to give a defense.
How are you going to give a defense?
What do you know to be able to stand there
and tell somebody what you believe and why?
So this is exactly what we start to see
and what your students are going to start to see
with Peter in their early stages of acts, right?
So if you look at what Peter says in acts,
we've got this guy who literally at the crucifixion ran away
but then all of a sudden in acts is proclaiming what he's seen and heard
and we see in acts 420, Peter say,
we can do nothing but speak of the things that we have seen and heard.
So there are just this massive compelling nature of them
to be able to speak about the things that they've seen and heard.
Now it is important to remember
that some people might not really think that this idea of apologetics
is all that necessary.
In fact, some might even say it's dangerous
and they might even look to passages like 1 Corinthians chapter 2
where Paul gives this idea that it's not by human wisdom
or human power that he comes to the Corinthian church.
That he didn't come with wise and persuasive words
and a lot of people will take this to mean that we don't argue
and we don't want to persuade people
but in the context that's not exactly what Paul is talking about.
So we are called to maturity.
We're called to be able to give evidence.
We'll see throughout this study if you look at the life of Jesus,
you'll look at the life of Paul, you'll look at the things that Peter did,
all of them gave consistent and good reasons
for what they believed and why they believed it.
So what we're really asking students right out of the gate here
is to consider that very question.
Why do you believe what you believe
and can you discuss those beliefs intelligently?
Why do you believe what you believe?
So you and your students are headed on a huge, huge journey here.
And it starts with getting students to start thinking
about these kinds of spiritual conversations.
Some of the stuff that we're going to be talking about
is some pretty heavy stuff.
Some of the topics that we're going to be dealing with
are going to be very challenging not only for you
but challenging for your students as well.
So you want to create a certain kind of environment.
Now some of you may already have this environment in your groups
and some of you may not
but I want to encourage you to create an environment
that really fosters this key idea
of being able to ask and answer questions.
Now this might seem really, really simple.
Like well yeah, of course my students can ask questions
but you would be surprised that the number of students
that just don't feel like they can ask any question.
Not just the difficult question
but maybe the question that just really questions their own faith.
That really sort of invites in this idea of doubt.
Now we're going to be dealing with doubt but much later.
So you have to be able to create an environment
where your students feel like they can ask anything.
Where they feel welcome where it's a safe place.
But that doesn't mean that you have to have all of the answers.
Because let's be honest, you're not going to have all the answers.
Your students ask great questions.
In all the years that I've been a Christian educator
I have seen some amazing questions
that you just sort of stand there with your jaw drop.
I don't know what to say to that
because I never would have thought of that question
and I love those kinds of questions.
Don't feel like you have to have all the answers.
But what goes even further than having all of the answers
is being able to walk alongside of a student and say
hey listen, I don't know the answer
but let's you and me figure this out together.
That's going to do exactly what our goal is.
That's going to create a stronger relationship
between you and your students.
As well as at the same time figuring out the answer to their question.
So use the resources that you have available to you
inside your church.
Possibly a school or a seminary that might be nearby.
Friends and family of yours that may have a deeper understanding.
But also use us.
We're here at awanowym.org
We have a ton of resources in a library that we are continuing to build.
Definitely check out Sean's website at SeanMcDowell.org
He's got a ton of resources and if you still are stumped
you can even contact us directly
and we are happy to help you in any way that we can.
We are here to assist you in this journey
but I can't stress enough.
Be sure that your small group leaders
and you in terms of a large group, whatever it is
that you have going on
make sure your students feel like they can do this.
That they can ask anything.
And it might start with you giving them some of the questions
that even you have in terms of figuring out what this looks like.
So get ready, dive in, don't hold back
and know that all of us here at the Home Office are praying for you.
Praying for each other and other groups around the country
that are on this journey with you.
As we navigate together what this looks like
as we explore deeper of what it means to be believers in Christ
what that looks like, how do we defend it
and how do we guide our students so that when they graduate
when they move on to bigger and better things beyond your youth group
they are prepared to successfully engage their culture
and further the Kingdom of God.